the name of my workshop is identity and
access control for modern applications
we will be covering all things related
to
user authentication and protecting web
apis mainly under the technology
umbrella of asp.net core this topic is
really useful for applications it's
crucial to how businesses design their
applications because the users are
obviously at the center of everything so
we will be covering the the latest
authentication infrastructure in asp.net
core how to do logging in users using
the new authentication handler system
we'll be supporting external
authentication like social logins and
modern security protocols like open id
connect as part of that we'll look at
how to design and centralize your
identity using an open source project
that i work on called identity server
and that helps enable your single
sign-on scenarios we'll look at a lot of
common application security
architectures around that and then
finally the second half of the workshop
will be covering web api security and
how to integrate that sort of security
from all the types of modern
applications we build these days like
web applications but also javascript
applications spa applications and
the native mobile style applications
that we built these days
[Music]